so i can bring you some breaking news
now the flag is flying at half-mast at
buckingham palace
uh the uk's prime minister
has announced
that uh the
if yes the flag is being
lured at buckingham palace
queen elizabeth ii
has passed away
the moment many people
never really imagined
would happen has now happened
the queen somebody has always been there
certainly if you live
or have lived in britain
even around the world
one of the most famous faces of all
so
we can confirm the news that queen
elizabeth ii has died
at
balmoral in scotland
uh her son with her death
her son charles
becomes britain's
new king
he will be king charles iii
queen elizabeth ii hugely popular at
home witnessed
so much life
and so much history
indeed the longest reign in british
history and now the flag is flying at
half-mast
over buckian palace
because the queen has died
she has been this
anchor
and a focus
for national identity and continuity
and represented
duty and dignity and decency
and so much as
change in the world in her lifetime
but the one constant
in the midst of all of that
of her more than 70 years
of being queen
has been her
well she was
96 years old born in april the 21st 1926
and came to the throne on the death of
her father in 1952
and became the longest reigning monarch
in british history
let's hear now from andrew simmons who
takes a look back at her life
in modern times no monarch on earth
could claim the level of popularity and
respect that queen elizabeth ii enjoyed
right into her advancing years
her rain was the longest in british
history marked in spectacular style by
the first ever platinum jubilee
scenes reminiscent to the end of the
second world war in 1945
she was celebrating
70 years on the three
[Music]
what a contrast to 2021 the year before
and this enduring image of a queen alone
with her sorrow yet stoic
the death of her husband prince philip
and a marriage that lasted 73 years had
focused minds on her remarkable reign
she wasn't born to be queen
her childhood was carefree here with
sister margaret
but then came change
at 10 she found herself as heir to the
throne her uncle king edward viii
abdicated her father became king she was
leading a very quiet family life
fairly out of the news when the
abdication came it wasn't her destined
role from birth and i think that her
father taught her incredibly well and
she learnt her
lesson very well as it were
princess elizabeth was 25 when she
assumed the british throne returning
from a visit to kenya after the sudden
death of king george vi
by the time she was crowned queen she
was 27 it was only six years after she'd
married prince philip the duke of
edinburgh a lifetime of service ahead of
her and the end of a naval career for
philip who'd be by her side for the rest
of his life
as she took the throne britain with its
empire was losing its grip on global
power
the queen's first mission along with her
husband was a royal tour as head of the
commonwealth she visited countries
preparing transformation to independence
from britain go back to the early 1950s
there she is
and it takes a bit to
get it through to your own mind that you
know this is a person who
who conversed with the churchills the
nehru's
their very early
commonwealth leaders the queen was able
to lift the dark cloud of colonial
attitudes ensuring the commonwealth
became a multiracial multinationalist
association it was perhaps her biggest
achievement and she was passionate about
the commonwealth throughout her reign
back home it might even look like a
normal life a love of dogs and a passion
for horse racing
the queen
she was herself a horse woman and she
loved the outdoors
as a mother though there were challenges
like all the best families we have our
share of eccentricities
of impetuous and wayward youngsters
and of family disagreements
the heir to the throne charles her
eldest son had become prince of wales in
1969
at the age of 32 he married diana
spencer she had just turned 20 and was a
stranger to royal life
it was an unhappy marriage ending in
divorce
then in 1997 princess diana was killed
in a paris car crash
initially the queen didn't publicly show
grief she was staying in scotland while
distraught crowds gathered at buckingham
palace i think diana's death was a very
dangerous moment for the monarchy i
think that was the was possibly the one
moment where you can look back on on a
pretty flawless reign
and say that at that moment i think the
queen lost her her judgment the queen
had a special affection for charles and
diana's two sons william and harry
prince harry was seen by royal watchers
as the queen's favorite grandson but he
was to take his grandmother through some
bad times
he married an american actress meghan
markle they left their royal duties and
moved to america as private citizens the
couple appeared on a u.s television
network with scathing attacks on the
royal family for making them unhappy
meghan markle said a member of the royal
family made racist remarks
the queen's personal life may have had
its ups and downs and family may not
have come first all the time while
british monarchs don't have absolute
power they can influence and steer their
political leaders a long list of prime
ministers followed in the footsteps of
winston churchill in their audiences
with the queen
each with a piece of history to share
with her boris johnson here the 14th
leader and the man who took the uk out
of the european union in 2020
he also had to handle the country's
response to the coronavirus pandemic
a crisis the queen addressed in a rare
tv appearance we should take comfort
that while we may have more still to
endure
better days will return
we will be with our friends again we
will be with our families again
we will meet again
queen elizabeth's adult life was devoted
to duty
how will she be remembered
i think she had assumed the status of a
national icon the nation's grandmother
her legacy
will be the fact that the royal family
is in a position to survive
and indeed
thrive that has by by no means been a
given throughout her reign
elizabeth ii queen of a commonwealth not
an empire had always shown unflinching
determination
[Applause]
in death as in life she'll be revered by
many millions here in the uk
and beyond
you